good morning
good afternoon good evening good night
wherever you are
whatever time it is where i am it's june
21st 2021
i am back in los angeles after a week
in miami florida and i've got a lot to
tell you
who am i i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report
direct message do me a favor people tap
that subscribe button the little drop
down will come
ding the notification thingy maybe
you'll see our videos
in your feed it's at least a possibility
uh we got a lot to catch up on i want to
share some personal stuff some business
stuff and then get to
all the news of the day i missed talking
to you good people when i was in miami
at about 11 o'clock pacific time uh
what's that that's in miami that's uh
what time is it there that's 12 1
2 2 o'clock eastern i'd just be
wandering the streets just talking to
people
about the news because i felt that i
need to get some of this stuff out
uh we got four stories for you today
plus i want to show you a little
something that we did
in miami we actually launched we debuted
live stream on locals in miami with
the mayor francis suarez it was such a
pleasure to be
with a mayor chatting with a government
official
who i liked who i felt was competent who
seemed like he understood the future
and wanted to build a thriving
successful city
as opposed to a mayor say of a place
like los angeles eric garcetti
or san francisco or portland or seattle
where i feel like the mayors would
rather have me jailed so it was really
awesome to be in miami
i taped a full interview with the mayor
we're going to show you one little clip
because we actually debuted the live
stream function
on local so now i can live stream talk
to you guys directly without
big tech involved we'll show you that
then just the four stories that we're
going to get to they all have a similar
theme and i do sense maybe the winds
are changing around wokeness because
it's getting so hysterical
charles barkley who is by far the best
sports commentator
that we have in america and probably has
been for the last 20 years not only
talking about basketball but doing his
thing with
uh kenny smith and and shaq and ernie
johnson
on on tnt and i used to love that show
like
absolutely that was the type of show i
wanted to do when i originally
wanted to get into sports broadcasting
you know 15 years ago or something like
that
he is leaving nba on tnt because he's
had it with wokeness and he's had it
with network executives
who are constantly worried about what
twitter trolls and everything say and
barkley's been basically the most
outspoken
person in sports for a couple decades i
mean really since the the early 90s if
not late 80s
so the fact that he's had enough really
tells you something and i'm gonna have a
message
directly for charles barkley uh then
this joy reid
person who is on msnbc which is a
democrat propaganda channel on your on
your cable
network or your cable channel thing
there uh she's not happy with chris
ruffo and as you know chris ruffo is a
friend of mine he's been on the show
several times
he is a lawyer and one of the leading
experts at getting critical race theory
out of the schools well
joy reid keeps going after him and
ruffo's basically challenging her to a
debate hey let me on the show let's talk
it out
she ain't biting and then speaking of
ridiculous people in cable news
don lemon and i will be upfront about
this i was once friends with don lemon
we used to go to dinner we'd hang out
uh but he's sort of gone off the rails
now he thinks america is coming for
black people
uh lemon of course lives in a four and a
half million dollar
house in the hamptons or in somewhere in
long island i think sag harbor or
something like that
uh and i believe he's married to a white
guy but he thinks that the evil white
people are coming for
black people in america it's just
complete nonsense we'll get into that
and then finally
it is pride month and the only thing
that i've done here
for pride month is i did have a
card-carrying lesbian on the show a
couple weeks ago as you remember
i've always i always say card-carrying
lesbian because to me if you're a
lesbian
you're like a full-blown lesbian they're
gonna give you some kind of card a
laminated card of some kind and you're a
lesbian you have to show it to people
well that's the only thing i've really
done for pride so we thought we'd do
another pride show
and up in seattle they are literally
charging
uh white people reparations to be
involved in the gay pride
parade so we're going to talk about that
all right here we go guys no ads today
i'm feeling good let me have a little
sip of coffee
it was just so spectacular being in
miami it really was like to be
in a place that you could feel it you
could it's tangible like
actually tangible like i could feel it
and partly because of the humidity you
can just sort of feel the atmosphere a
little bit more it's very humid in the
summer
but like you could just see there was
such an explosion of
interesting people coming down there i
met so many people that were like yeah i
just moved here
or i'm here now or real estate agents
were going crazy
i met uh well you're going to see my
chat with
francis suarez the mayor of miami we're
going to put that up next week i'm going
to show you a little
piece right now but i also sat down with
gabe groysman who's the mayor
of bell harbor it was just it was just
great can you
am i being clear about my feelings here
it was just great anyway i want to show
you just a quick
50 second video we debuted live stream
on locals this is a massive
technological jump for us so anyone that
is a creator on locals
can now live stream without worrying
about youtube taking your stream down
without worrying about instagram or
facebook or anything else
you own it we just build it for you and
you can do it so we debuted it
with francis suarez in miami
on location i've got the mayor francis
suarez
i've got my local's partner and uh we
just taped a cafecito talk and an
episode of the reuben report
and uh mr mayor it's working in this
town
it's working it's working because we
make it simple we believe
uh we should keep taxes low keep people
safe and have the best quality of life
of any city in the world and uh we
respect people's choice to
live anywhere and be anywhere that's why
it works can you guys believe i still
live in la this is really twisted
um asap we held livestream until we were
in miami yes this is great so guys this
is the first live stream that we are
doing we are super happy to be here with
the mayor we just announced that we are
open our headquarters here
and i think the city of miami will help
us to basically try here
absolutely and uh getting your
headquarters here and get down there
headquarters here
uh it is essential to our narrative and
our story that we're building here
the most innovative most creative city
on the planet and
we need your help yeah and we built this
thing and we
waited until we were in miami to show it
so any creator can fully live stream
without worrying about whether they're
on youtube or twitter or they're going
to get kicked off anything
you absolutely own it all your people
can chat with you right there can't wait
to get my own
yeah we're good we're going to get you
are you going to get hurt you heard it
right there
suarez on locals all right we got work
to do gotta go thanks everybody do you
think that might be affirming for a guy
like me to like sit with the mayor who
wants my company to move to the
city that he's mayor of that wants to
use the technology we're going to work
on
getting mayor suarez on locals we think
we're going to build a local community
for
the city of miami i'm just thrilled with
so much going on down there and yes we
are hiring
in miami right now so if you uh want
to see the jobs that we've got listed go
to locals.com
jobs and one other thing he said he
wants to keep taxes low keep people safe
respect choice it's not rocket science
people
how you free people and all that good
stuff oh and i'll just say one other
thing about locals and then i promise i
will move on to the stories of the day
which is that i could be kicked off
these things at any given moment we we
know that like that's just how it is
lab leaks talking about election
whatever it might be like we're all just
here by the by the grace of the youtube
people so even if you don't want to
spend a couple bucks a month uh to
interact with our content on locals you
can create an account for free and all
of our stuff
and i can't know i should say that fully
correctly most of our stuff is
absolutely free there
so you can still see it and view it and
listen and that sort of thing you just
can't interact
with it directly and then at some point
if you want to you can throw in a couple
bucks so you go to
reubenreport.locals.com okay that's it i
promise
for the commercials let's talk about
charles barkley as you guys know i am a
huge basketball fan if i was doing
anything else in the world if i could
have my dream job it ain't this it's
playing
professional basketball that's what i
would rather do i still got a pretty
decent three and a pretty sweet
finger roll unfortunately i'll be 45 on
saturday and i've got a torn acl and a
bum shoulder but besides that
that's what i would love to be doing i
love basketball and i also love
broadcasting because i do love what i'm
doing here
and charles barkley is a was a great
basketball player who became
an incredible broadcaster i mean for as
phenomenal as he was on the court he
became probably even a better
broadcaster
in some respects and he did this show
nba on tnt for the last like 20 years
with shaq and ernie johnson and kenny
smith and it was it became what what
television is supposed to be at its best
which is sort of this feeling of a live
interactive
interesting fun conversation around
whatever the topic is in this case
basketball but then it became cultural
and at moments over the last 20 years
had some political parts to it
but then as you guys know locism has
infected everything
and then it became endlessly political
endlessly about race
and i haven't watched the nba in years i
actually just saw on twitter yesterday
the final i guess minnesota no milwaukee
and the
suns or something and two other teams
the clippers may be in somebody else
or like i just don't even know what's
going on in basketball i don't even care
anymore but i thought this was
fascinating barclays basically had it
and is announcing that he's leaving
the nba on tnt and i think for good
reason so let's listen to the audio here
and then charles i'm gonna make you an
offer
i mean it's got so out of hand right now
i couldn't imagine having to watch
myself you can't even have fun nowadays
without these uh
jackasses trying to get you counseled
and things like that
so i uh especially you being a comedian
yeah but still just
just having fun talking about sports
like
like like listen i'm trying to hang on
for another couple years till i'm 60
and then they can kiss my ass because i
i'm only working to 60.
that's that's all we ever talk about
behind the scenes now like
yo man be careful going in this
direction i'm like yo man
we can't even have fun anymore we've had
fun all these years and all of a sudden
in the last year and a half
everybody's trying to get everybody
fired and it really sucks
but unfortunately uh i mean
it's been happening for a couple years
now like if people disagree with you
they're gonna get
fired but they're coming for your head
you know and a lot of our bosses are
cowards
i mean that's it right there like the
guy loves this
really think about this this is one of
the best professional basketball players
of all time
a transcendent guy like he you know
there's a few people that sort of
transcend
the sport michael jordan was bigger than
the sport of basketball barkley
was bigger than the the sport of
basketball there's other guys that do it
in in different sports right kobe was
bigger than the sport of basketball for
example
then he's had fun and enjoyed doing
broadcasting and bringing his love to
other people and talking about in a fun
way and all that stuff
and wokism ruined it so now he's looking
to get out and he wanted to say i'm
going to hang on a couple more years and
then they can kiss my ass
but his point was not that he doesn't
love this anymore it's what it has
become
because if you listen to the expanded
clip it's that the executives at the
network are constantly worried about
what
twitter trolls say and losing sponsors
and everything else so here it is
charles barkley i'm going to clip this
very thing right now i've already talked
to my guys my agents and everything
we're going to send you
this clip directly we've got some
contacts with you i want to give you a
piece of locals i will give you a piece
of
my company to join locals and open your
own community and do whatever you want
and own your video and audio and live
chat with people and live stream
and all of that stuff just to be on
there because i love you man
you should be in the game there's no
reason you should be getting out of the
game at 60
and i get it you don't want to be at a
network anymore and guess what networks
are dying and you leaving is an exact
perfect example of why they're dying
because a guy like you
who just wants to say what he has to say
and and say something honest and real
and true and have some fun
you're you're fodder now for a network
like that they want they want robots
they want endless racialization of
everything
and man i want to help you out so i will
figure out a way to give you a piece of
a company
just just so you can get on there and
continue whatever you're doing
and oh and i just want to say something
else about about barkley in general and
what's going on with sports i mean we
know that all the ratings are dropping
out right
basketball ratings have absolutely
plummeted we know that uh
nfl ratings have plummeted i think if
i'm not mistaken and now i'm happy to
say it
nhl which i've never been a hockey fan
but after that video we showed you two
weeks ago
of the islanders game six against the
bruins in long island when everyone
started singing the national anthem i
think hockey ratings
have been pretty good and it's funny the
sport from canada has become the most
pro-american sport there is
um all of these things are are not
disconnected like we really are in an
up ending of everything and i think you
guys can see it now a lot of people
can't see it because they watch
mainstream media that'll be a sort of
through line to everything else that
we're going to talk about today
but we should want some people out there
in mainstream
still making some sense so when a guy
like barkley who does make sense by the
way and when he talks about politics
even though it's not really what he
wants to talk about
he does make sense when he talks about
how you know basically
everyone is trying to racialize
everything and that you know all
everyone's trying to turn everybody
against everything it's like he gets it
and by getting it he has to step out of
the system so barkley
chuck i love you man one of the saddest
moments of my life
1997 game six against the utah jazz
when stockton hit that three and knocked
you and clyde and akeem
out of the playoffs i i watched that
game every now and again and it's very
sad the last minute
and uh i wanted you guys to win that i
wanted you to get your ring
but i want to give you another ring i
want to give you a ring of freedom man
so join me with locals let's see what
happens all right let's move on
to the next story so joy reid i've
talked about her a bit over the last
couple weeks now it's kind of funny this
is one of those things which i've
addressed before
when these people do these ridiculous
things on cnn and msnbc
nobody's really watching right like
msnbc's ratings
are terrible they're hugely funded by
giant corporate behemoths
they have massive staffs probably 20
upwards of 50 people on some of these
shows i have no idea exactly how many
they have at this point
but they have huge staffs they have huge
budgets
multiple producers directors everything
else as i always say to you guys i got a
i got a producer sitting right there i
got a director sitting right there i got
an intern
who's working from home and and then
what i say here it just it's whatever
coming out of my mind i got a couple
notes and that's it but you get these
over produced shows
that are are basically democrat
propaganda that that's what joy reed is
she's a
she's a democrat propagandist by the way
you can find some very anti-gay writing
of hers that msnbc never addressed from
about 20 years ago now of course if she
was on the right she would have been
cancelled and destroyed
but she's a lefty she's a democrat she's
a progressive so
so that's okay when you do that anyway
she's been going after chris ruffo and
most of you know chris ruffo i've had
him on the show a few times
he is a lawyer and what i love about
chris is he's a fighter
like this isn't a guy that's just
talking about stuff this is a guy who
has taken
the fight against critical race theory
against
race essentialism against the idea that
you are born
guilty because of your skin color in
this case white against the idea that we
should racialize
everything and that traits that once we
thought of as good things
like showing up on time and working hard
and knowing empirical facts like two
plus two equals four
that somehow these are white things and
these are things that must be destroyed
and that the founding of america
was evil because it was through white
people and all of these things and that
and that the
the real thing that brought america
together was slavery i mean these are
all nonsensical things
that are being pushed in all of our
schools they're they're one of the
reasons that everything seems to be
falling apart
we did a clip last week of barack obama
basically implying that that critical
race theory is not something to fight
against which tells you that it actually
is something to fight against the fact
that he even had to
go out there and say that because it
shows that the fight against
critical race theory is starting to work
right so texas
florida several other states have now
passed laws
banning critical race theory being
taught in schools the same way you
wouldn't want nazism
say taught in schools you could teach
about the nazis but you wouldn't want to
teach
that the nazis with their racialist
ideas about the world
were the good guys right so chris is
doing an absolutely great job and he's
been calling out joy reid
and well she called him out on her show
this is a guy named christopher ruffo
who's at the conservative think tank
uh at a conservative think tank and he
says the goal is to have the public read
something crazy
in the newspaper and immediately think
critical race there we've decodified the
term
and will recodify it to annex the entire
range of cultural constructions that are
unpopular with americans
basically using critical race there is a
brand name oh absolutely it's a
distraction
it's a distraction okay i'm not even
sure who that other person was but
all right joy reid is sort of going
after the ideas that chris ruffo has put
out there there's many other moments
where she's been mentioning him
so chris did what you can do at least
for now
on a semi-free internet he tweeted at
joy read he said
joy reid has denounced me by name
multiple times on her show
but she doesn't have the courage to
invite me on as a guest she knows that i
will crush her
critical race theory apologetics any day
of the week so in essence he said hey
look i put some stuff out there
you don't like it you've mentioned me by
name put me on your show let's talk
about it now i've been through
many versions of this myself right where
mainstream people go after me
cnn or new york times and i used to
challenge everybody debates and they
they usually just disappear
well then joy responded and really
listen to there's a particularly crazy
part of what she said here she wrote
this is a weirdly aggressive way to get
yourself on
tv christopher why not just contact my
booking producers like a normal person
rather than going with the white man
demands option
capitals on white man demands i had
never even heard of you until
underscore peace exposing your plot
to rebrand crt now okay it doesn't
matter when she heard of him she's
talking about him a lot now and making
him seem like he's some sort of
conservative bad guy because he's trying
to get race
uh obsession out of schools but there
she went ahead and did she already
showed her hand there first off what was
the line white what was it white what
now
white man demands options so now she
racialized this conversation
she now looks at roofo and the and she
views him
simply as a white man so through the
critical race lens
right through this lens where they
racialize everything well she did it
there she even put those words in
capitals
so is a white man not allowed to ask to
be on a show
demands you're talking about him
and now he's asking
to talk to you so this is what they do
with everything by the way
i'm going to guess that it is possible
and i'll ask chris myself i'll actually
text him after this
i'll ask him if he went through the
proper channels whenever anyone anytime
i've called out somebody
online i always go through the proper
channels first and you always get
ignored so what would have happened i
would bet
anything on this is if chris went
through the proper channels
he's just ignored right and then he has
to go public now maybe he didn't but
also
in the world of twitter and the way we
all communicate with each other if
someone calls you out
on their national cable news channel
show you're allowed to tweet at them and
say hey
you know can we talk he wasn't he wasn't
really being a dick about it
i don't think and then the end there
you're the until the piece
exposing your plot to rebrand critical
race theory he's not trying to rebrand
critical race theory he's actually
explained
critical race theory quite well what
he's trying to show people is that when
you hear these crazy things in the media
that nobody fully understands and why
we're watching kids come home thinking
that their parents are racist
and the country is awful he wants them
to understand that that is directly
linked
to being taught the ideas of critical
race theory
but it's his plot i know it's his plot
it's very it's very very scary so
hopefully they will talk
i i sincerely doubt that they will um
not that
joy is going to go for it but i would
gladly offer them this channel if they
don't even want me in the way
i'll offer them this channel and my 1.7
million subscribers or whatever it is
to just get the message out there if
they just want to stream it right here
that would
uh be just fine with me but again this
is about
fighting back and you know i always tell
you the thing i don't like people who
just talk
and i think a couple years ago a lot of
my liberal friends were just talking
about talking
and just not really doing anything i
like people who build things
and i like people who fight and chris
ruffo is like the tip of the spear
of the fight on critical race theory and
it's just great and we'll see what
happens
with uh with miss joy reid but do google
joy read in her anti-gay writings and
then wonder why this woman is still
on msnbc let's move from one
mainstream media hack to another uh you
guys know
don lemon over at cnn and again i said
at the beginning i was friendly
with don i don't know what happened to
him it's disappointing
to me a couple years ago you know we
used to go out for dinner and hang out
whatever and then
one day he just unfollowed me and then
sort of just you know followed me on
twitter and then just sort of
started going crazy with all this race
stuff it was not something that he was
doing before
he was actually a pretty moderate guy
from what i know i actually thought and
i think i've said to him privately
i think we're out to wings once on the
upper west side and i was like don i
think you're a conservative we kind of
laughed about it
well he's really just gone in on all of
this
nonsense uh we've got some quotes here
from blaze media
cnn anchor don lemon had some
unfavorable remarks about the united
states and americans in a new interview
the left-wing cable tv host
made a bizarre claim that americans
don't see black people as human beings
and declared that the u.s needs to
realize just how racist it
racist it is i don't know if america
sees black people and especially black
gay men
as fully human and as uh deserving of
the american dream lemon said
lemon claim that we're living in two
different realities as black and white
people
but as the daily mail pointed out he
lives in a 4.3 million dollar
four-bedroom cottage in sag harbor on
new york's long island where 80 percent
of the population is white
and just three percent are black okay i
don't care how much money don lemon
makes i don't really care
where he lives or the price of his house
i'm a capitalist and i believe
that if you can make the money and do uh
well i was gonna say an honest day's
work i'm not sure he's doing an honest
day's work but
i don't think he's doing anything
illegal let's put it that way it's like
you know what
if you're making money and you live in a
fancy house on long island
good for you okay but that's not really
what this is about first off where is it
better for black people
than america i'll be silent for ten
seconds can you count to ten
please think of all the places it's
better for black people than america
yeah that's how many that's how many now
that doesn't mean it's perfect
that doesn't mean it's perfect and it
ain't perfect for anybody because
there's no such thing as perfection
we humans are flawed thus we build
flawed things but america is pretty damn
great
and that's why black people are not
fleeing america and that's why black
people
world over are still trying to come to
america and so are other such brown
people
and often white people it's very very
bizarre so that's just nonsense
uh absolute nonsense and i mean i say
the same things all the time but it's
like just worth repeating that we fought
a war
to end slavery we just put
june 19th as a national holiday like
there's a whole bunch of stuff here
lemon and that they don't like black
gay men like what are where are black
gay men being hunted down where are
black people being hunted out you know
where actually
chicago chicago you may have seen some
of the videos this past weekend
of just people being shot on the streets
i mean there's some really horrific
videos
of black on black crime in chicago i
know we can't talk about that and even
me
saying that watching black people get
shot down i mean mowed down by gun
violence in chicago
that makes me a racist i know that um
but here i am i said anyway can we find
out how many people were shot in chicago
this past weekend it's usually around
40. it's about 40 people usually a
weekend and then usually about
5 or 10 of them die but that's black on
black crime so we can't talk about that
although
mayor lori lightfoot who's black and
said that she'll only be interviewed
by black or brown people uh she just put
10 million dollars of her
city's money in chicago to fight racism
which that's just a way of like paying
off people that's literally just a way
of
10 million to fight racism you got
people being shot on the street
here's 10 million dollars to a bunch of
organizations that just don't do
anything
but they fight racism oh 52 people were
shot
in chicago this past weekend five
fatally according
to the chicago sun time guessing you
didn't see any of that on mainstream
media because
again it's that narrative over truth and
reality that they don't really like
but let's just be clear america does not
have a problem with black people the
only people that
have the obsessive people who are who
are
constantly harping on race are the
democrats are the progressives are the
lefties
nobody cares nobody cares about race
anymore
you guys care about race and the better
things get about race
the more you have to focus on your
imaginary problem
and what they are going to do i mean
i've been saying this for quite some
time already
but what they are going to do they are
going to breed a generation of racists
because if you keep telling
white people that they're all evil and
then you make it harder for them to get
jobs and they're harder to get loans and
all of those things
eventually you will create racist people
because nobody
is guilty over the color of their skin
nobody is born
guilty these people are in an absolute
cult and the idea that nobody
nobody likes black gay men you're a
black gay i mean that's what you
are
right it has nothing to do with you
being black and it has nothing to do
with you being gay
your ideas are idiotic you're on a prime
time show making millions
of dollars a year to live in a
multi-million dollar house in long
island
while telling us all how horrible we are
god these people are fools
anyway speaking of fools let's talk
about gay pride up
in seattle it is gay pride month very
exciting
there's a whole month devoted to gay
pride spectacular stuff
now it's going to involve reparations
because you know you can't
you can't just be proud of who you are
without grifting some money
off undeserving people we've got some
quotes here from
770 ktth radio organizers for a seattle
gay pride event
say they're changing white charging
white people
a quote reparations fee to attend
they have the support of city council
president and mayoral candidate
lorena gonzalez and the seattle human
rights commission taking black pride
organizers say all are welcome to attend
however white allies and accomplices
must pay the reparations fee it will
be charged on a sliding scale of ten to
fifty dollars depending on
one's ability to pay critics question
whether
race-based admissions fees are
appropriate
seattle municipal code clearly prohibits
racial discrimination but organizers
have pushed back
calling criticism of their admission
structure
casual violence god these
people are complete racist idiots now
first off
what's hilarious here is this is a gay
pride event right
so if you were gonna charge people
reparations
wouldn't you be charging straight people
not white people
but for some reason they're charging
white people i mean if we were at least
keeping this in the somewhat box that
this thing's supposed to be in if you're
at a gay pride event
and then straight people want to come i
wouldn't be for this but it would be
like if you want to charge
the straight people more but no they're
making it about white people because
intersectionality is the greatest
idiotic moronic grift
of all time and makes everyone who even
dances with it
for a moment just that much stupider so
these people are the ones who want
systemic racism imagine if you're just a
white person so that means
what that means is you could be a white
gay guy right you're a white gay guy and
you show up
to the to the black uh pride of it and
it's like hey guys i'm here for you i
want to celebrate
and it's wonderful we're all gay and
lesbians and stuff
like okay can i come in and they're like
well how much do you earn because we got
to chart figure out how much you charge
you it's slightly scaling well i'm a
dance instructor so
i don't know can i do 12 dollars it's
like well you know is your boss white
and what do that do it's going to be 15
for you
we need to build new things you see what
i'm saying here people that's what
really what i learned
in miami is that there are going to be
places built that are going to be built
right now and that are going to lead us
to the future
that are going to build great new things
and i think miami is going to be a part
of that florida is going to be part of
that texas and tennessee and some of
these other
red states and red cities are going to
just start building things like the
people who don't want to play these
nonsensical
endlessly racial endlessly destructive
games are going to go ahead and build
things
that's what i'm going to do with
locals.com and as i said earlier if you
want to work
for us we don't care what color you are
we don't care what skin color you are
and we don't care what sexuality we
you are but we'll pay you less if you're
white and straight because
locals.com jobs if you're interested in
that if you want more about all of this
stuff if you really need like a quick
uh recap on what's going on with
critical race theory and why it's so
dangerous my full episode with james
lindsay who has been one of the leaders
on this for years now that's up on
youtube right now and of course you can
get it on locals
uh ad free uh by the way part one of my
interview with michael knowles who has a
new book
called speechless and i'm i'm quoted in
there no big deal
uh that'll be up tomorrow in the full
episode we'll be up at
reubenreport.locals.com and his new book
is for sale tomorrow if you didn't know
this books by mainstream publishers
always published on tuesdays
that's a little info for you uh speaking
of books i'm pretty much done with my
book now
i think i told you guys my book editor
was here last weekend we plowed through
a bunch of stuff
we're going through the last bit of
touches we finalized some stuff about
the cover
and i'll announce something soon we'll
go on pre-sale right before i go off the
grid at the end of
july and the book will be out in april
and
i'm going to keep building things i'm
going to keep finding the people who
want to build things
and i'm going to keep exposing these
ridiculous frauds what are you going to
do
let me know in the comments right down
below see ya
you